every sport makes different demands on
an athlete a soccer player needs to
sprint repeatedly for 90 minutes and
change direction in a heartbeat a
baseball pitcher needs to turn
rotational energy into a blazing
fastball a sprinter needs massive
straight-line speed and acceleration
different types of athletes are suited
to different types of sports if you want
the absolute best performance you need
to train that athlete to optimize their
strong points and minimize their
weaknesses that's what they do it's part
of sports science by focusing on the
attributes of each individual athlete
the golden question we get a lot is you
know who's the best athlete and you know
responses to be what's the best painting
my name is Phil Wagner founded sparta
performance science in 2008 the tailored
approach to evaluating and improving
athletes is at the forefront of the
sport science work pioneers worked with
many professional athletes including
major league all-star Tyson Ross of the
San Diego Padres as well as Los Angeles
Lakers guard Jeremy Lin helping him go
from a marginal NBA player to a phenom
when an athlete comes in this far for
the first time movement signature is
captured by performing a vertical jump
on a force plate how we interact with
the ground explains so much of how an
athlete is in their sport and it's all
based around how you time and some are
shorter and quicker others are really
explosive others are just slow and
strong we're looking at how much force
is put in the ground initially and then
how well that force is transferred from
that initial creation to the final
prolonging of force production the three
phases are the load which is how quickly
you can develop that force the second
bar or you explode is how will you
transfer that force and the final bar is
how long you produce force or you drive
you want it to be relatively level and
number one risk is any signature where
one value is exceptionally high we see
baseball players with an extreme drive
because most of their movements tend to
be producing force for a longer period
of time if they don't have enough load
to initiate that force we've been able
to statistically associate it with elbow
injuries will give squats to that player
to improve their load but still have
that drive there at the end to create
that rotational movement over time as a
weight increases on a certain movement
because you're getting better at it you
will force plate signature changes in a
certain way as well and so we've
associated the two trajectories of the
exercise improvement and the force play
improvement and start coming up with a
true treatment plan that's based off
evidence I've been you know plagued by
injuries majority of my career I've had
three knee surgeries and and since
working with Bill and Sparta I found out
why and and how to protect myself as
well as trying to get better we've seen
more and more personalization in every
aspect of our lives by playing that same
mindset one that almost seems like part
of Silicon Valley to the sports world
Sparta is helping each of its athletes
to try and realize their full potential
you